Vita Cyril ligac ou encore Bruno Guillon
la liste ne cesse de s'allonger toutes
ces célébrités ont été victime de hjing
soit d'un cambriolage commis à
l'intérieur d'un domicile en la présence
d'occupant alors y a-t-il une
recrudescence de ces vol par qui
sont-ils commis une catégorie de la
population est-elle particulièrement
visée parmi les personnes ciblées on
retrouve des personnalités publiques
voire des célébrités dans la nuit du 20
au 21 juillet 2023 le gardien du PSG Jan
Luigi donaruma et son épouse sont
victime d'un homme jacing des inconnus
masqués les ligottes et les frappes sous
la menace d'armes avant de les
dépouiller les personnes connues ne sont
pas les seules victimes des anonymes
sont également touchés les cibes sont
assez diversifié parfois elles sont
repérées sur les réseaux sociaux donc il
convient d'être quand même très vigilant
sur l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
mais ça peut toucher également des zones
résidentielles où de fait il y a des
maisons cossues qui peuvent attirer
l'attention de ce genre d'équipe quant
au profil des auteurs de ces vols quel
est-il les auteurs de homejacking ont en
général deux profils différents un
profil soit de professionnels un petit
peu AG guuéri des équipes qui ont déjà
fait ce type d'action donc des
homejcking et qui arrive pour vraiment
commettre des violences dans le but de
voler les effets et puis d'autres
profils et c'est la deuxième catégorie
d'auteurs un petit peu plus jeunes et
qui ont du mal parfois à maîtriser la
situation et qui utilise de la la
violence parce que justement ils ont du
mal à maîtriser la situation ce serait
peut-être le cas du hjing réalisé au
domicile de Bruno guillaon le 11 octobre
2023 deux mineurs âgés de 16 ans ont en
effet été mis en examen pour le
cambriolage avec séquestration commis
fin septembre chez l'animateur les
quatre malfaiteurs l'avaient menacé avec
une arme puis avait ligoté et bayonné
son épouse dans la chambre de leur fils
de 14 ans si les exemples récents ne
manquent pas le HJ King n'est pas un
phénomène nouveau l'OM jaing il a
commencé dans les années 1990 c'est un
phénomène qui est assez ancien savait
pas de nom anglais on appelait ça le les
les affaires de saucissonneur des
affaires de saucisson pourquoi parce que
c'était des gangs qui avaient l'habitude
d'aller chez leur victimes donc en
forçant le domicile et après en les
ligotant comme des saucissons et donc on
appelait ça le gang des saucissonneurs
il y avait eu pas mal de pas mal de
grosses affaires assez retentissantes ce
gang des saucissonneurs ciblait les
grandes fortunes dans les 7e et 16e
arrondissement de la capitale à l'époque
une princesse Perse le parfumeur Guerlin
ou encore l'épouse de Charlas navour
avait notamment été attaqué on se
demandait comment ces fameux
saucissonneurs donc les ancêtres du
hjcking arrivaient à cibler leur victime
et à l'époque il y avait pas Internet et
ils avaient donc d'autres d'autres
méthodes ils é is notamment le beautin
mondain ou le Wozou qui sont des des
annuaires de personnalité ou figurent
souvent les les adresses il y avait
aussi des lieux dans lesquels allaient
les les personnalités notamment ils
pouvaient les repérer à la sortie de de
grands restaurants parisiens ou alors
même sur des sur des champs de cours
comme à Longchamp ou ou pendant des
Grands Prix avec les nombreuses
personnalités touchées récemment on peut
imaginer peut-être à tort qu'il y a une
augmentation des cas de hjing au niveau
national il y a moins de 500 faits par
an donc c'est des faits qui sont peu
nombreux c'est circonscrit mais de toute
façon un fait sera déjà beaucoup trop
parce que il s'agit d'une infraction qui
est extrêmement traumatisante pour les
victimes et nous avons une tendance qui
est baissière ces dernières années entre
2022 et 2023 par exemple on a une
dizaine de faits qui sont en moins donc
une tendance baissière pour les
dernières années alors comment expliquer
cette impression de recrudescence c'est
un phénomène qui est plutôt en baisse
ces dernières années mais qui ont ces
derniers temps toucher particulièrement
des personnalités ce qui attire
évidemment l'attention des
médias